[Musique]
chez adonis la poissonnerie attire une
clientèle qui préfère le poisson entier
avec une clientèle multiethnique
je pourrais dire que moi c'est 70% de
mes ventes cd poisson entier ah ok dans
les marchés traditionnels c'est moins de
1 % surtout vendu enfilait le poisson
gagnerait à être cuisinés entier
vraiment qu'ils découvrent la saveur à
l'intérieur de poissons à cesser
complètement différent beaucoup plus
juteux et sa couronne aux petits bobos
et fiable qu'est ce qui fait selon vous
que le poisson ac est meilleur mais vous
pour vous toujours les rails les eaux
vont donner beaucoup plus de goût lors
de la cuisson
[Musique]
en prime il reste frais plus longtemps
qu'une personne qui achète un poisson
entier peut les garder un bon courage
aux quatre jours dans son friche dalle
dont c'est l'oubli s'est pas trompé le
parc anti âge est un filet puis lobby
deux trois quatre jours risquent d'être
périmés donc l' avantage de se procurer
un bois sont aussi françois nous propose
quatre poissons facile à faire o'barry
ku et cause pour les québécois c'est sûr
que les plus gros vendeurs c'est la
truite arc en ciel entier non seulement
c'est repos ensuite deux seules une
belle doral
il faut absolument qu'elle désire et ça
c'est un vrai délice une dorade royale
qui vient de la grèce produits d'élevage
des cieux cher facile à faire au baryton
ensuite le loup de mer vers ceux-ci
vraiment un must
je fais j'ai conseillé ce à plusieurs
clients les clients sont venus sont
tombés en amour avec ce poisson locke
complétons avec un poisson sauvage le
vivaneau ans après vente sur enceinte ne
bougeait plus le vivaneau là mais ce
postulat même poisson pour le même
poisson du tout pour découvrir le rouget
qui est le sénégal le 10 de nos qui
viennent des etats-unis dans ces deux
savoir faire
[Musique]
c'est sous la supervision de françois
qui a 30 ans d'expérience en
poissonnerie que je fais cuire mes
premiers poissons entiers
d'abord en papillote
donc ici on a la belle truite arc en
ciel c'est les points on commence à
quels sont les bras toujours à
l'intérieur on va mettre les oignons une
petite rangée de nyon on ajoute citron
haye et les sommes qu'on aime comme le
thym ou le romarin excès
donc on bourre la vente généreusement
peut voir elle est bien farsi alors on
note barre à l'extérieur sur le dessus
de la truite alors ça c'est un fumet de
poisson qu'ils vont nous donner quoi un
peu de goût bien soin de goût et aussi
de vapeur alors la cuisson si on n'a pas
ça qu'est ce qu'on fait un bouillon
poulet ou un petit peu de vin blanc on
enveloppe notre truites dans deux
feuilles d'aluminium que l'on place au
barbecue 30 minutes à 350 degrés où les
plus détruites
on ne touche pas on ne tombe pas de côté
on attend tout simplement que le temps
s'écoule par la suite aux malheureux
tirées çà va être est ce que ses racines
non on peut faire ça absolument tout le
mans 2e techniques directement sur la
grille
c'est la recette la plus simple qu'on
peut faire la deux pas de farce on va
écouter directement comme seuls 3 des
incisions extérieur carli on trippe sur
ça sert à quoi voilà chers la chaleur va
pénétrer plus rapidement puis on eu une
cuisson plus uniforme on ajoute une
marinade maison d'huile d'olive de
curcuma et de cumin en la règle de base
c'est 2.5 cm d'épaisseur égale à 10
minutes de cuisson
même principe pour le loup de mer en
votant le plus simplement possible de
niveau mais de sel et du poivre à
l'intérieur et extérieur
on va prendre un couteau et on va le
marquer encore une fois par contre on
mettra pas de marinade cette fois ci
alors lorsqu'on va façon venir ici
pendant break 5 et 10 secondes voici a
pas de feu qui monte et qui va brûler
notre poisson
si on constate que l'armée sous contrôle
donc observer notre couverte et puis on
va calculer environ 6 à 8 minutes de
chaque côté
c'est peut-être le plus important
demandez à votre poissonnier de retirer
toutes les nages ou très très important
monsieur quant aux abonnements sur le
barbecue ça va se mettre à flamber à
brûler sur la pac thermomètre à la
maison on peut utiliser bordel boboto
network sûrs de savoir si si ça et ça
sort facilement c'est cuit
ce qui semble définitivement qu ici
autre avantage de cuir un poisson entier
les arêtes s'enlève en un tournemain
voit bien se rappeler de plus beau en
termes de filet mais ce que ça fait
c'est que les arrêts devons rester ici
je m'aide un peu toi c'est tellement
bien que ça se libère et là ça va pas
ici truc comme ça que tu fais comme ça
excellent pop complique donc là on a
tout notre chair de poisson très frais à
fond dans la bouche
aucun petit bien troisième technique la
cuisson au panier ça va être pratique
parce que ça va empêcher la poutre collé
sur la grille
lafarge tombe également donc on va cuire
norad sur les greens pendant 6 à 8
minutes sur un côté à mi-cuisson voulait
retirer gauche françois terminer la
cuisson des daurades en ajoutant
directement sur la grille des arbres qui
ont trempé une heure dans l'eau pour
transformer notre barbecue en fumoir et
les herbes simplement infuse à
l'intérieur du poisson réalise qu'on
goûte bon appétit
[Musique]
les pêcheurs bretons sont le poisson
nous conclure immédiatement pas
grand-chose seul point une boîte 6
auxerre
alors amusons-nous en cuisant n'importe
quel poisson entier avec l'une ou
l'autre des trois techniques et
découvrons ainsi les multiples saveurs
que nous offre la mer